all right so this topic
is probably one of the most important
videos that i will ever do regarding
your health i didn't know what to call
it so i titled it the most important
antioxidant is melatonin not glutathione
but this information is completely brand
new you've never heard this before and
it's very important information now a
few weeks ago i interviewed
dr roger schwelt it was a fascinating
interview related to vitamin d
and there's one point at the end where
he talked about
some of the studies not really coming
out that dramatic with your immune
system using vitamin d
and then he said something that really
got my attention he said that it was
probably not just vitamin d he said that
if they did the studies with actual sun
not just vitamin d you'd probably see a
much better outcome and then he sent me
this this paper that literally blew me
away and i put the link down below and
this video is a summary of that paper
and so people
they want to live as long as possible
why do people die
well the great majority of people die
because of heart disease that's the
first cause of why people die the second
cause
is cancer and the third reason why
people die is related to
some metabolic illness it could be
diabetes it could be alzheimer's it
really depends on what country you live
in but typically it's related to
some metabolic underlying cause and
what's common about all these reasons
why people die is that they're all
mitochondrial diseases
in other words there's some type of
dysfunction that
destroys the mitochondria with cancer it
originates in the mitochondria the
mitochondria become damaged and then
that cell then converts over into a
cancer cell now with heart disease we
have a lot of free radical damage
whether the person's on a high carb diet
or they're a smoker or they have a lot
of oxidative stress then we create this
irritation or inflammation
in the inner arteries but that damage is
being created in the mitochondria and so
if we really look at the
essence of where the problem is we're
getting this
excess of
oxidative stress
and free radical damage
normally our body
is supposed to protect against that okay
and the way that it protects against
that is through the antioxidant networks
there's certain enzymes that act as
antioxidants one being glutathione it's
considered the most important
antioxidant but guess what melatonin is
even more powerful and more effective
because melatonin is not only an
antioxidant it triggers other
antioxidant networks including
glutathione i mean melatonin is twice as
powerful as vitamin e and we know the
importance of vitamin e to prevent heart
disease inside the arteries so melatonin
is a very powerful antioxidant and it
triggers
other antioxidants now you're probably
saying right now wait a second i thought
melatonin was really about helping you
sleep it's involved in the circadian
rhythm it helps
people take it if they get jet leg and
maybe you've heard something about how
melatonin is now used to help your
immune system since it's now considered
an immune modulator to help you regulate
your immune system and of course i won't
mention specifics but it's very very
powerful against certain viruses
and on top of that there's a lot of
research on how it's an extremely potent
anti-cancer
compound or a hormone all right so maybe
you already knew that but what you don't
know is this there are two forms
of
melatonin there's a type of melatonin
that is in your blood circulatory system
as well as inside your pineal gland and
your pineal gland makes melatonin
stimulated from darkness okay
but there's also another type of
melatonin that is subcellular that means
it's inside your cells
and it's inside the mitochondria
and the reason why it's there is to help
protect against the massive
oxidation and free radical damage that
usually occurs in the mitochondria so
there's two forms of melatonin
circulatory and subcellular
this part right here
the mitochondria that's inside the cells
is the great majority of the melatonin
in your body in fact there's some new
data
that indicates that the melatonin in
your pineal gland is really only a
backup or supplemental to this other
system so if you don't have enough in
your cells then it'll actually take from
the pineal now guess what's going to
happen if you don't have enough in the
pineal
it's going to affect your sleep
your quality of sleep is going to be
crappy
you're going to get inflammation and
you're not going to have the antioxidant
protection and there's a whole list of
problems that can occur from that not
just poor sleep but chronic inflammation
chronic degenerative diseases especially
of your brain
do you realize that there's a condition
called sundown syndrome which involves
people that have alzheimer's disease and
dementia
so apparently when the sun goes down
45 percent of people with alzheimer's
and dementia they start getting very
agitated they get extremely fatigued
why do you think that is because they're
running out of
melatonin they don't have enough
melatonin now at this point you're
probably completely confused because
typically melatonin is the hormone of
darkness okay because everyone knows
that the absence of light stimulates
melatonin however there's some new
information so if you've checked out
check back in because this next part is
very very very important
the largest stimulus
of this intracellular
melatonin
is
near infrared aka
the sun certain wavelengths of the sun
will stimulate the melatonin inside the
cells
and darkness will stimulate the
melatonin within the circulatory system
in the pineal gland in fact over 50
percent of the sun's
energy is infrared and this goes way
beyond the benefit of getting vitamin d
from the sun you ever notice why when
you sit in front of a campfire you feel
so
relaxed and you probably sleep a lot
better because natural fire
gives off infrared
campfires are very therapeutic or why
you might feel very relaxed if there's
candles around the house infrared when
you use incandescent lights okay those
are the lights that have been around
since the 1800s the type of light that's
generated from a heating filament
versus
led which uses a completely different
technology
incandescent lights give off
infrared and unfortunately the entire
industry is moving away from
incandescent lights we have moved into
the area of artificial lights led blue
lights aka your computer
cell phone in fact there is a very
interesting study which i'll put a link
down below
that demonstrates children in
predominantly artificial light end up
having a deficiency of gray matter and
having a much more difficult time in
learning this is also why
there's so many therapeutic benefits to
an infrared sauna and there's a huge
trend in people buying infrared lasers
infrared therapies
for pain inflammation and
sleep so
melatonin is not just a hormone of
darkness but it's also a hormone of
sunshine the other cool thing about the
sun is that even if you have a hat on
okay
the grass the clouds the dirt strongly
reflect
infrared
waves so you don't have to be looking
into the sun if you're outside you're
going to get infrared indirectly now i
just want to tell you a little side note
on that topic
presently i'm living on a farm
and the two neighbors that helped me a
lot on my farm are both in their 60s
their diet is
is not just
inadequate
their diets are absolutely terrible okay
they live on sugar
one choose tobacco the other one smokes
now both of these guys
are outside
all day long okay i don't even think
they have computers i don't even think
they have a cell phone they're just
outside working the land all day long
and they rarely seem to get sick they
don't really have any health problems
they're both super strong
but they eat like crap
but
they're getting a tremendous amount of
antioxidants that is repairing the
oxidative stress that's repairing the
free radical damage and it's just
interesting to know
what's important and maybe what's less
important and i really didn't emphasize
the importance of the sun for your
health and simply because i didn't have
this data right here this infrared
information as well as its connection to
increasing melatonin but apparently as a
therapy being outside in the environment
in nature and being exposed to sun is
extremely important probably just as
important as eating healthily now the
other cool thing about infrared is it
has the ability to penetrate your skull
now that's mind-blowing in this research
paper they talk about how it penetrates
the cerebral spinal fluid and how that
can just bathe the entire brain and
spread to the entire spinal cord it's
just it's wild so this is just another
reason why if someone's getting dementia
or as alzheimer's they should be exposed
to sun and the cool thing is this
infrared protects against
uv
radiation so if you're concerned about
the sun causing cancer i understand that
we're not talking about being out there
and getting burned we're talking about
being out there and maybe even getting
the sun's indirect energy from the grass
but the point is that this ir
helps you generate a tremendous amount
of antioxidants that can potentially
protect the mitochondria from having its
complications from all that free radical
damage that occurs now if we flip that
and talk about what creates a deficiency
of infrared well being exposed to
artificial lights led lighting
blue light
cell phones computers so here people are
they're sitting in their home all day in
front of the computer or they're at work
sitting at their desk in front of the
computer and by the time they get home
it's already dark out well understanding
the importance of melatonin and having
enough melatonin to protect against all
this other damage so it's not just about
that vitamin d from the sun it's about
melatonin now a couple things you can do
in addition to getting outside more and
more
you can get one of these therapeutic
lights and expose yourself to near
infrared 20 minutes a night before you
go to bed that could be something you
can do you can switch out your lighting
system to more incandescent lights you
can have more fires in your fireplace or
more candles or campfires but anyway i
think this is a fascinating topic and if
you haven't seen my video on the
therapeutic benefit of the sun i put it
right here check it out
you